Adult Swim set animated series Rick and
Morty is chock-full of sophisticated
ideas vulgar weirdness and well
high-concept sci-fi rigmarole which
makes it one of the twistiest and time
vendhya shows on television fostering
hundreds of ideas about the show's
alleged secrets some fast stranger than
others hold on to your brain buckets and
try to keep up with the seriously
bizarre Rick and Morty fan theories not
the real more say let's start off by
flipping your whole world upside down
and saying that the Morty Smith we've
been watching lately isn't the Morty we
started off with this notion is part of
a larger Rick and Morty master theory
which postulates that Rick's original
Morty got trapped inside one universe a
tragedy scene during the opening credits
of each episode when Morty falls over
and is almost eaten by giant frog
creatures left to fend for himself in a
world of monsters this Morty grows to
resent Erick and orchestrates the event
scene in close Rick ounces of the Rick
kind in order to take down all Rick's in
all universes we see something like that
happen in the season 3 episode the Rick
lantus mix-up in which politician Morty
becomes president of the Citadel of Rex
shake what power President Morty
assassinates a number of members of the
shadow Council of Rex and then a
slow-motion sequence of legal documents
and floating corpses is revealed that is
none other than evil morte with how
often reticles Morty disposable we may
have called dozens of Morty's our own by
now most timelines have a wreck and most
rick's have a morty this place is a real
who's who of who's you and me and
honestly is that that much difference
between one Morty and another we both
know that if there's any truth in the
universe
it's that Rick's don't care about
Morty's not the real Rick beyond Oh
Morty not being true blue our wreck
might be an alternate version as well
one theory is I reckon that his life
when Beth was a child explaining why he
was missing from a life for 20 years the
wrecked our viewers know now would have
been alive in a different dimension
separated from Beth and his ex-wife
unfortunately this Rick royally fluffed
up his timeline and needed a quick
remedy discovering a universe in which a
version of himself was dead
our wreck jumped into that timeline and
the rest is history we've even seen
something like that happen in the series
so any Rick as possible and if this
Rick's been gone for 20 years how can
there be a picture of him holding baby
Morty he's only a
major now and how can you actually
remember holding Mort a plot hole or
secret hint that things are even more
messed up than we know the universe
which it's time to unpack the ricky
matee theory known as the ticket theory
which connects the episodes multi night
run and Total Recall to suggest that the
latter episode is happening in a
universe that isn't the one our usual
Rick and Morty operates in according to
the theory the universe swap happened
when Rick and Morty picked Jerry up from
the Jerry Barea
hey wait do you have five one two six
I'm not sure Morty that's a Blitzen [ __ ]
ticket what way to go Morty yeah
whatever the Shocker here is that the
ticket Rick and Morty are given at the
beginning of Morty night run is numbered
5 1 to 6 but they took home a different
Jerry hang on to this that numbers your
dad if you lose it we're not gonna be
able get him back the audience actually
follows here widget no Jerry into his
new universe and leaves the original
Rick and Morty behind how else would you
explain the arrival of mr. poopy
butthole a few episodes later who's
treated as though he's been there all
along at least as far as this universe
is concerned one in the same
Rick and Morty share a number of similar
qualities and even the same voice actor
but they can't actually be the same
person can they according to one theory
they 100% totally are as Rick and Morty
are walking through the Citadel you can
spot what appears to be a combination of
the pair in the same physical body while
he could be an odd alternate dimension
Rick Morty the theory suggests that he's
actually an older Morty and younger Rick
as far as the blue pants go it's pretty
simple you said me used to wear blue
pants lastly there might be a surprising
link between Diane Sanchez Rick's
ex-wife and the staff member of anatomy
park Annie both ladies look surprisingly
similar
Andy grew close to Morty during their
adventure together but Rick ended up
shrinking her and trapping her in a
container
what the hell Rick what the hell man I
liked her the ferry hence the mossy now
as Rick freed and he later in life so
they could be together baby cronin Morty
the creepy uz Cronenberg creature from
autoerotic assimilation was a standouts
even compared to the giant praying
mantises and deformed beasts that ravage
the earth and wreak potion number nine
but the pint-sized monster could hold a
harrowing significance if you consider
this next theory the only time Rick and
Morty viewers have ever seen record
genuinely connected to anyone has been
with baby Morty no I'm just allergic to
dip this makes it all the more
heartbreaking to speculate that the
Cronenberg creature from the episode is
actually a baby Morty from a different
dimension though the moment has passed
off as Rick trying to test his invention
this theory suggests that he obliterated
the baby Cronenberg who he actually
shows affection for as part of a
contingency plan in another universe I
got Cronenberg baby Morty became a
victim of the Cronenberg plague so Rick
put him in stasis until he could find a
cure
Rick's final act of mercy was to
euthanize the Cronenberg Morty as he
only cure was to kill it after all the
problem got so bad that record to
abandon an entire planet because he
couldn't or wouldn't fix it Beth's real
mother mums the word for this theory
which argues a Beth's mother is actually
the hive mind entity unity' seen in the
season 2 episode or 2 erotica simulation
what if Rick's previous fling with unity
led to one of the entity's hosts an
earth-like humanoid getting pregnant
unity eventually left Rick but not
before separating from the pregnant host
that would become best mother which
makes for a really really weird
situation to raise a child in seeing as
how best mother wasn't in control of a
body when she met Rick or conceived a
kid with them the theory supposes our
best real mother now in control of her
own body would force Rick to leave so
she could bring her bath by herself I
don't know if you can appreciate what it
means to grow up without a father
unity being best real mother would also
explain why it was so protective of
Morty and summer when they visited its
planet treating them to endless
hamburgers and sending in a special
force team to rescue them it wasn't just
because their Rick's grandchildren it
was out of a deeper maternal instinct to
keep them out of harm's way thanks
grandma
BRIC self-awareness the idea that Rick
knows his part for television show is
one that is long circulated throughout
the Rick and Morty fan community but
does Rick's self-awareness go deeper
than simply acknowledging as
two-dimensional existence
think about it Rick understands are the
only reason he's alive is because of a
creator Dan Harmon to be exact this
notion grounds itself in the photos seen
hanging on Rick's wall which is a
drawing of Harmon or maybe it's just a
picture of a bradawl fling claw but only
the smartest man in the universe would
have a legit pic of god right that is if
he's not in total denial there is no God
summer rip that band-aid off now you'll
thank me later the theory also explains
why Rick drinks almost constantly and
easily breaks the fourth wall as a man
of science Rick turns to alcohol because
he's unable to reconcile with there
being an actual God he knows he's being
watched and understands that once people
stop tuning in to Rick and Morty his
world is destroyed forever
keeping the series alive is the only way
to keep himself alive
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something about Tricia just
summer Smith a classmate Trisha Langa's
little more than her shiny brunette
locks and nice body but she may be far
more mysterious than she lets on what if
Trisha is actually a Galactic Federation
agent just like Somers old pal Tommy
sent to dimension c-137
to spy on Rick to gain new Intel after
the falling outs and betrayal that took
place at the end of season two in a lot
of ways what I really AM is a deep-cover
agent for the Galactic Federation and
you guys are a group of wanted criminals
nothing that they can no longer spy on
the sanchez Smith family by friending
those close to Rick the Galactic
Federation instructed Trisha to spend
time with Somers boyfriend Ethan and
become best friends with Morty's crush
at Jessica allowing her to gather
information without seeming suspicious
the theory notes that Trish's vulgar
language is exactly how Tommy spoke when
she was working undercover and although
the theory doesn't mention this it might
be worth noting that Tommy and Trisha
are voiced by the same person
Rick's real plan another popular Rick
and Morty Theory postulates that in the
season 3 finale wreck intended to kill
Morty in not Jerry the theory points to
a particular moment
the episode that happens just after
Morty steals Rick's portal gun and takes
Beth summer and Jerry to a secluded
cabin to hide from wreck while he
trashes the White House though Morty
believed his hiding spot to be
unguessable by wreck he ends up at the
cabins doorstep a gun in hand that
degree everyone Beth Or worried that
she's actually a clone of herself
guesses that Rick brought the gun to end
her life
Rick it quickly clarifies you crazy
[ __ ] you're my daughter
I brought this here to kill Jerry Jesus
Christ this was just a cover-up for his
true intentions
the real threat isn't Jerry but rather a
Morty with his own portal gun or even
worse an evil Morty with a portal gun
especially since Morty's been getting
smarter and smarter as the seasons
progressed when Rick sees the family is
fine he just shifts his anger towards
Jerry because really he's Jerry so take
your attitude to the men's section of
Kmart cuz you need to cut me some slack
too weird for words and then there are
the fun theories that are just too
bizarre or too unlikely to ever be
considered canonical for example there's
the insane idea that Rick's real ex-wife
might be get this miss Frizzle from the
Magic School Bus series based on the
idea that both fictional characters
explore the weirdest areas of space and
the human body okay people this whole
thing and what about the idea that Rick
purposely abandoned his daughter to
cause her to act recklessly get pregnant
at a young age ruin her life and to pop
out a couple of brainwave jamming kids
sure except Rick could probably just
clone or kidnap whatever kind of Morty
he wanted because he's Rick fidgets
spinors in one half-baked theory they're
just this reality's version of the
Google box and ice cream it's basically
the Rick and Morty version of the answer
to every question in the universe
because well they talked about it a lot
well why don't I get Beth and we'll go
out for ice cream
Jerry this was the most romantic weekend
I've ever had
thanks to Cold Stone Creamery I was
gonna hop over to the gloppy drop system
get some ice cream
fun facts about this one it's got giant
telepathic spiders eleven nine eleven
and the best ice cream in the multiverse
and Galactic Federation agent tummy in
one bonkers theory she's actually Rex
long
to mention hopping granddaughter based
almost exclusively on the fact that
Tammy has a similar hair color to Jerry
whoever came up with this one well
pretty dumb
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love tea